Hallelujah.
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
the chapter of vigilance of Allah's
observation authored by
the sixth narration in that chapter
the 65th narration
in total
the narration of Ebihore
and we reach to the part where the angel
came back to the previously leper
who once was previously a leper
and asked him for one camel. and he came
back to him in his original form and he
turned him away and failed to
acknowledge Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
blessing upon him.
The prophet sallallah
says
He said, "And then he came to the bald
man in his image and in his set of
circumstances that he first found him in
all those years ago."
And they had a similar dialogue. They
had a similar exchange exactly the same
as with the abos.
To which the angel responded, "If you
are
not truthful, if you are lying about
what you say, then I ask Allah to take
you back to what you were previously."
He says,
"He then came to the blind man or the
or the man who was formerly blind
in his
image and in his
previous set of circumstances."
And he said to him, the angel said to
the blind man,
he says,
"I am a very poor man and I am cut off
from my homeland. I'm out here and I've
been cut off with no money and no way to
get home.
And there is no way for me to get back
to my
homeland
without Allah's help and then yours.
I ask you by the one who had previously
restored your vision, one sheep that I
may use to get back
that I may use as a means to return
to my land.
Here's a question.
a blind man
who is allegedly traveling.
He's poor.
He's cut off from his homeland
and he asks for a sheep
to get home.
How much sense does that make? Where how
did he get here? What are you doing
here? A blind man. You came all the way
from your you've traveled all the way
out here and and now you don't need a
horse. You don't need a a donkey. You
don't need a mule. You don't need
something to ride. You need a sheep. A
sheep to get home to get all the way
home.
It doesn't make a lot of sense, right?
It seems something is missing.
It's very clear to almost see through
that. Correct. Right.
Most people would look at that and say,
"This guy is this guy's trying to trick
me,
right? He's trying to scam me."
However,
what
is the point of this? Why is the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam telling us
this? This here goes back to the
intention
of the man who is being tested.
His intention
is to help. His intention is to help.
And his intention is to take this man on
his word.
I'm not going to be able to do a federal
background check on this man to make
sure that he is indeed poor and he is
indeed a blind man. I'm not going to be
able to further investigate and
scrutinize and make sure
this is the situation that has presented
itself. He has taken the man at his word
and he sees himself in that man. He sees
himself in that man who people
misunderstood previously, who people
overlooked, who people didn't care
about, who people accused, who people
thumb their nose at. And so he said his
response,
he said, "I used to be a blind man and
Allah restored my sight." Now he didn't
have to remind him the previous
two.
He didn't have to remind him because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
the reminder is beneficial for what type
of person
right those who want to remember but if
somebody already has made the decision
that they don't want to remember
what benefit is reminding them
he hadn't forgotten genuinely and so
even without being asked
He was proud of this. He was proud of
the fact that Allah chose him to bless.
He was proud of the fact that he has
humble beginnings and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
chose him as a showcase for his
miracles and mercy. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so he says,
"I used to be a blind man and Allah
restored my restored my vision."
So take whatever you need and leave
whatever you whatever you choose.
[Silence]
He said, "Take what you need. Leave what
you want. For I will not blame you for
anything that you take. If you need it,
take it. I I owe Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. and I've just been waiting for
somebody to act as a conduit for me to
pay back my debt, to pay my dues. This
is the
this is the acknowledgment that the
man has which is his greatest strength.
[Silence]
He said, "Keep your wealth. This was
merely a test that Allah has tested you
and the two other men with,
and Allah has thus been pleased with
you, and he is angry with the two
others.
And so
this narration
not only is a reminder that we are to
seek
answers and seek knowledge and seek to
prepare for our test before the test
begins.
If you wait until the test begins to try
to start getting ready for it, you're
probably going to fail the test.
And every single one of us right now,
right now,
every one of us right now is going
through this same
approximate test.
Every one of us right now is going
through this same approximate test. Not
exactly the same way. We didn't we
didn't , you know, come upon some
windfall fortune overnight. we didn't
have perhaps some miraculous
you know healing
that we you know from some illness
that we suffered from. Some of us did
maybe
some of us have. However, in one way or
another to to one degree or another,
every one of us is essentially testing
right now being tested with these same
exact with these same exact parameters
these these very similar
things and that is will we see
ourselves in others? Will we remember
our origins? Will we acknowledge Allah's
favor upon us? And will will we extend a
hand when we are most under the illusion
that we don't need help? This is the
question and this is the purpose of our
lives.
Foreham
[Silence]
speech.